[SPEAKER_04]: the alignment of stars.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if we ever doubted whether it's important that we industrialize, the shocks have told us, in fact, it's not important, it's a must.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we think about the alignment of frameworks and trade policy, we're just at the right moment with the ASCRT now ready for implementation.
[SPEAKER_04]: I say this because there's no way to talk about trade investment and economic productivity outside of thinking about how that alignment
[SPEAKER_04]: gives us an opportunity.
[SPEAKER_04]: So let's step into capturing this opportunity.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'd like to start, I don't see Dr. Hassan.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mahmoud?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so let's go to Anastasia from UNCTAD, my former home.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ms. Anastasia, in the current environment characterized by trade fragmentation, what specific industrial policies must African states deploy to strengthen their trade resilience and prevent
[SPEAKER_04]: erosion of their production and export capacity.
[SPEAKER_02]: And one of the key steps that we would be recommending to countries pursuing further regional integration and coping with fragmentation is to have industrial – a set of industrial policies which now have to include technological and financial levels.
[SPEAKER_02]: We see that advanced economies are using them much more actively.
[SPEAKER_02]: especially in their finance, especially in their capital market regulations, financial flows, and of course currencies, but developing countries are yet still too close to go down.
[SPEAKER_02]: At the same time, one comment on trade.
[SPEAKER_02]: Trade is indeed, there is a paradox to trade.
[SPEAKER_02]: Global trade flows reached a peak last year, the year of huge
[SPEAKER_02]: trade uncertainty, trade policy anxiety, and investor fear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merchandise trade flows closed at 34 billion in 2025, a historical record.
[SPEAKER_02]: So in many ways, of course, it's a testament to how negotiated the shock was, how global economy avoided the worst-case scenario, the AI boom that drove investment and financial dinners at the financial centres.
[SPEAKER_02]: At the same time, it's also a testament for a very changed matrix of world trade, where global south is much more present.
[SPEAKER_02]: So out of 20 big trading hubs today, in 2024, we measured them last year, 11 economies are emerging markets, are global south economies.
[SPEAKER_02]: In 2007, that number was only six.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's quite a massive increase.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, this diversity partly explains the resilience.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yes, there is much more opportunity to diversify.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is much more opportunity to trade.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is active search for new trade partners.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, not one of those new 11 economies, a trading house, a global trading house, are African economies.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there is still a lot to fulfill and multi-layered
[SPEAKER_02]: challenge to overcome.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of such challenges is overcoming not just the commodity curse or the resource curse, but the financial curse that comes with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: We saw in the early 21st century, in the first commodity boom that was very much sensed in Africa, how statistically growth went up.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then we saw how little macroeconomic transformation was actually put into place.
[SPEAKER_02]: So now with the energy transition, with the demand for minerals and food commodities that is projected to go up, so for food commodities, it's estimated to go up by 50 to 60% by 2050, globally.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's demographic, it's climate, it's major changes to agricultural systems.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Africa stands, just as we saw in the morning, Africa stands to gain a lot.
[SPEAKER_02]: but it needs to introduce a variety of integrated policies to also embed the commodity revenues and avoid the financial bubble or the expansion of the fire sector.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fire is finance insurance and real estate that typically suck a lot of resources out of the productive economy.
[SPEAKER_02]: They employ some people, but not all.
[SPEAKER_02]: and they have quite marginal or differentiated productivity gains.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Anastasia, let's drill a bit deeper on this question of productive capacity in commodities, for example.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there one, two specific actions that governments should take to build productive capacity of commodities?
[SPEAKER_04]: What would you say?
[SPEAKER_02]: We measure capacity and Africa is, in fact, going ahead much faster than many other emerging markets.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think it's not a simple problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: Africa is home to more than 60% of the best solar resources, but it received only 2% of green investment in 2014.
[SPEAKER_02]: also means that you need to have that ecosystem of measures to make the commodities work for you, not just for the commodity owners.
[SPEAKER_02]: Targeting corporate power is one, targeting the recapture is another, and pursuing the transition where the jobs are is the third.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, very interesting, because I think Magis said something similar earlier.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to move on now to Dr. Melanie Raymond and talk about, you know, French shoring strategies, ETC.
[SPEAKER_04]: So as many countries advance resilience supply chains and French shoring, how can partnerships with countries like Canada more effectively support tech transfer, industrial upgrading, and the development of resilient value chains while remaining aligned to Africa's strategic priorities?
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I would like to highlight two success factors.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or at least I think they are possible success factors.
[SPEAKER_03]: I won't pretend I know the truth.
[SPEAKER_03]: First, I think the key word that needs to be understood
[SPEAKER_03]: and to find if partnership exists.
[SPEAKER_03]: So what is an effective partnership?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not just two people talking.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's two parties coming together on a mutual footing and that are both ready to consider each other's perspective and trust in the search for a mutual beneficial solution.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's not trivial.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can talk to a lot of people
[SPEAKER_03]: But if you don't have those ingredients, it's not going to work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Canada has a track record, but has also done its homework.
[SPEAKER_03]: So when you're choosing a partner, you should visit the track record to see if the partner has done its homework, just as much as have you done your own homework.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Canada has recently launched Africa's Geology Project.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have done our homework.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we did it by talking to over 600 stakeholders, not just Canadians.
[SPEAKER_03]: We talked also to international stakeholders, but most importantly, we talked to African stakeholders.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we're not shy.
[SPEAKER_03]: We will tell you, we are doing this in our own interest.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we have interest.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we are also really interested in our partners' interest.
[SPEAKER_03]: Canadians' interests are about strengthening our economic resiliency, as well as increasing our trade hours ratio.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we also have looked at the agenda in the 63rd, and then we found where there was commonality.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if you are interested, you can look up Canada's strategy, which has the title of Partnership for Shared Prosperity and Security.
[SPEAKER_03]: The second success factor is that partnerships should be based on trust.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, we all know trust is difficult to build.
[SPEAKER_03]: It has many elements.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, in the interest of time, I will just focus on one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Knowing what your partner stands for, its values.
[SPEAKER_03]: Canada is needed to rule these frameworks.
[SPEAKER_03]: You keep saying it,
[SPEAKER_03]: We keep getting there, we keep showing up.
[SPEAKER_03]: But that is important in our relationship with Africa.
[SPEAKER_03]: It also requires transparency and predictability.
But in those days, we were touched with credibility and transparency.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that, business wants.
[SPEAKER_03]: Businesses all around the globe, doesn't matter their nationality, they want predictable,
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm thinking specifically, let's get an example.
[SPEAKER_04]: Either tech transfer or industrial upgrading, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: How would you advise Africa completely in these two areas to structure partnerships with Canada?
[SPEAKER_04]: So African countries typically would say, well, we have tax holidays.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is our investment regime.
[SPEAKER_04]: How can we take that to the next level completely in a particular sector, in industrial upgrading, for example, or in value chain?
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, on the completely front, I think, so Canada has been working with the African Continental Free Trade Area,
[SPEAKER_03]: We are here, we are working with the institutions.
[SPEAKER_03]: What I would offer instead of answering the question, sorry, I'm gonna change the question, is maybe more of a pragmatic reflection.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's basically Canada's received experience.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's the one of being mindful of the risk of concentration.
[SPEAKER_03]: Canada,
[SPEAKER_03]: Canada's trade is very concentrated, and it has in the last, let's say, two months, three months, made us realize how we are vulnerable.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so that's why we are talking in Canada about diversifying our economic relationships.
[SPEAKER_03]: So not just to reduce vulnerability, but really, in reality, strengthen our economic resilience.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so, if you don't underscore how diversification can be mutually beneficial, then you're kind of missing the point.
[SPEAKER_03]: But Canada, Canadian companies, and African companies can only benefit from diversification.
[SPEAKER_03]: They just need to create the right conditions, and that's the particular issue, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's about the transparencies, it's about certainty.
[SPEAKER_03]: Canadian companies, there are companies, companies in Africa.
[SPEAKER_03]: We are a very strong nation.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have a great number of economic assets as well as companies.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so let's, Steve, thank you very much for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's stick with partnership and get some more reflections from the Japan side.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I come to you, Dr. Tetsuya Harada, to talk about trying to answer maybe something of a similar question from the FDI perspective, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: So in your view, how can governments better ensure that FDI promotes effective technology transfer and fosters domestic ownership and absorption of these technologies rather than resulting in end-plate type development?
[SPEAKER_04]: So, from Japan's perspective, how can we better ensure that FDI delivers technology transfer and domestic ownership?
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Tetsuya Harada, and I'm a chief representative for Europe in JET office in France.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I'm based in Paris.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, before maybe I come to the link with you,
[SPEAKER_01]: between foreign investors and domestic farms.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, let me thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, I'm honored to be here, and this is my first time to be in Abidjan, but two days ago, I talked with the head of our office here in Abidjan, and it was surprising, but he still knew, but three months, three months ago he came to Abidjan.
[SPEAKER_01]: But now he's receiving a lot of business from Japan almost every week.
[SPEAKER_01]: So even though Japanese companies who are sort of cautious, their interests are really emerging.
[SPEAKER_01]: So no one can really ignore the potential of the private sector development in Africa and continent.
[SPEAKER_01]: Regarding the technology transfer issues, so my probably thought is that how this hypothetical business interest towards Africa can be sustained and translated into long-term development including through the technology transfer.
[SPEAKER_01]: In my view,
[SPEAKER_01]: If you look at the case of Asia, a lot of Japanese companies invested in other Asian countries, like Southeast Asia countries or now South Asia countries.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was really based on the long-term relations.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Japanese company expected the long-term relations with those countries
[SPEAKER_01]: And the farms are also expecting a long-term relations.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's why our company also invests not just say facility or factories, but also human resource development or building a supply chain with local companies.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the issue is how well we can have such a long-term relations
[SPEAKER_01]: countries.
[SPEAKER_01]: So recently we very often talk about the mutual interest.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is also a buzzword for development cooperation field as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if we look at the history of Japanese development cooperation, actually the trade and investment and also even development cooperation are reinforcing each other.
[SPEAKER_01]: But again, the underlying assumption is that we are building a long-term relationship with those countries.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, just I'd like to repeat the importance of long-term relationships and trust.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I prefer using the word mutual trust, mutual context.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so
[SPEAKER_01]: how can I say, at the moment, you know, we talk about a lot about a fragmented world or a much poorer world, and now you are having a loss of more power, you know, negotiation power.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's really good development, but the small message that I could talk about is that please also do not forget about those, you know, long-term innovations.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not just about the business field.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who can offer the best deal?
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we were to think about joint ventures as a modality for Japan-Africa partnership, especially because Japan has strong capabilities in technology, what would you advise is the best way to
[SPEAKER_01]: execute those joint ventures completely so that business partnering with african business in a particular sector industry yeah how can we do it um of course um in a business field one of the important issues that's the size of the market right so uh for example the
[SPEAKER_01]: when Japan invests in other Asian countries, what we see is the potential of that market.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what the AFP-FCPA is doing is really a right move.
[SPEAKER_01]: And JICA is also supporting that movement by funding infrastructure, portals, or trade presentation like OSDP.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, of course, another issue could be the growth as well, because if we'd like to have a joint venture, again, particularly for domestic market, you know, particular growth, I mean, stable growth is very important.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, say, for example, automobile sector
[SPEAKER_01]: There was some sort of a rule of some numbers that if your income level is more than 5,000 per capita, and then there is more benefit for investor to move the production base of automobile in that country.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's sort of a big industry.
[SPEAKER_01]: But now you have a lot more diversified possibility, not just manufacturing, but the service sector, digitalization, logistics, healthcare, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: But again, so I think a good market size and also purchasing power increase is a stable, particularly important factor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, thank you very much for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very useful, also bringing in the services component.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to come to you, Dr. Constantine Negreloff, from the South African Reserve Bank, and you're going to talk to us about inflation and tackling these issues.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the recent disruptions to global supply chains have stopped inflationary pressures across Africa, while also slowing growth momentum.
[SPEAKER_04]: So how can African central banks deal with the heightened inflationary environment without choking private sector credit?
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you, Julie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me start by highlighting the importance of macroeconomic stability.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was highlighted by Professor Rang in his presentation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monitoring policy is an important part of macroeconomic stability, and the importance of macroeconomic stability is illustrated in those surveys.
[SPEAKER_00]: as well as competitiveness measures.
[SPEAKER_00]: So OECD, for example, has conducted a survey of pension funds in 2021 and 2022, which looked at what are the considerations that are, what are the things that pension funds think about when they invest in jurisdictions.
[SPEAKER_00]: And political risk, political policy uncertainty, and macroeconomic stability are listed as number one.
[SPEAKER_00]: This morning, this is it,
[SPEAKER_00]: I finished with a very powerful message, and she said, Africa's time on Africa's terms.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if you don't have macroeconomic stability, if you're facing a fiscal crisis or you're facing a type of balance of payment crisis, it's not your terms.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's the IMF's terms, really.
[SPEAKER_00]: So macroeconomic stability gives you the freedom of having economic sovereignty.
[SPEAKER_00]: and it's also about creating an enabling environment for various types of workforce.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me tell you how we think about supply shocks.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, the South African Reserve Bank is not in the business of advising other central banks.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think central banks on the continent face very different conditions.
[SPEAKER_00]: What we may be facing might be very different than what other central banks are facing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so the starting point for us is when we see supply shocks there,
[SPEAKER_00]: several trade-offs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any economic policy has trade-offs.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so I'm going to highlight three of these trade-offs.
[SPEAKER_00]: The first one is the common one that you're all familiar with.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is that monetary policy in the short term requires some output to separate parts of the total situation.
[SPEAKER_00]: That works against a different trade-off, which would be more medium to long-term trade-off.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is that if you tolerate high inflation in the short term, that creates
[SPEAKER_00]: or increases inflationary expectations in the longer term, inflation volatility, and hence increases also inflation risk premium.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so the short-term trade-off works against the long-term trade-off.
[SPEAKER_00]: The third trade-off, which is very, very specific to supply-side shocks, is getting wrong the second-round effects of a supply-side shock.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the trade-off goes like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you react too quickly,
[SPEAKER_00]: And the second-round effects turn out to be much smaller than you're imposing on this economic cost and the economy.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you react too late, you might have to have much higher interest rate increases, which in turn also increase the economic cost.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so this is a difficult thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so let me tell you three things that help you deal with these kind of trends.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the first thing is about
[SPEAKER_00]: trying to figure out the second-hand effect.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dr. Omotoshi yesterday spoke about the importance of data in this session, and I think here it's very important in the central bank to develop analytical tools, diagnostic tools, to figure out when we have second-hand effects.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is, for example, things around dispersion of prices, dispersion of inflation expectations, the size of the shelter management.
[SPEAKER_00]: The second thing which is very important,
[SPEAKER_00]: and very obvious, is monetary policy credibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: To give you an example, in the case of the South African Reserve Bank, in 2022, we had to have smaller interest rate increases than other central banks.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, because we had built up significant credibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two, because of the active credit earnings in our shop.
[SPEAKER_00]: That kind of distinguished emerging markets to the faster problems.
[SPEAKER_00]: The emerging market generally reacted sooner, had smaller increases.
[SPEAKER_00]: based on kind of build up to the ability over a period of time.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's advanced economies in that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just to link that specifically to this question around the macroeconomic stability, how would you link it in terms of approach to building this economic productivity capacity?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there something you can do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so if you take my example with the pension funds,
[SPEAKER_00]: or my protocols in general, or the issues around inflation in this period.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would you invest in an economy which is currently experiencing a fiscal crisis, or is facing inflationary pressures?
[SPEAKER_00]: What kind of a blended instrument will help you invest in an economy which is currently in a debt restructuring process?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the critical thing here is that macroeconomic stability is not going to generate growth rates of 5% or 6%.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it will certainly give you the enabling environment and other policies to generate those types of increases.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see it across the world.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so that's, I think, really, you know, if you think about it, it's fine to focus on structural reform.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if you don't have the macroeconomic stability to do this,
Because again, you're not going to be able to stay in the United States.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Prof, I'd love for you to think about what he said vis-a-vis Africa's own experience, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: In macroeconomic stability.
[SPEAKER_04]: And maybe give us a reflection in a few minutes on how to land that in industrial possibility.
[SPEAKER_04]: You know?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I think that's, I want to land it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I come to you so you can think about it?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'd like for you to, Dennis Novi from STDO, you have a very short deck for us.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know if it's standing by, the colleagues in IT.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you could show the deck quickly, please.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you can take us through its highlights very quickly on the trade with Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: Colleagues in IT, is it there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you ready?
[SPEAKER_04]: So you have three minutes.
[SPEAKER_05]: I want to say very briefly how important the relationship is for us in the African development.
[SPEAKER_05]: When we go to the next slide, I really have to speed up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, the backdrop is simply that we talk about trade and productivity in order to alleviate poverty.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is the bigger picture over the last few decades.
[SPEAKER_05]: We have seen a big drop.
[SPEAKER_05]: and poverty, but in particular, we can see that in East Asia, but also in Africa to some extent.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I want to highlight one bit on the map, which is the shaded gray area, which means no data.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's actually a big problem that we face.
[SPEAKER_05]: We'll go to the next slide.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, that decline in poverty is actually related to or correlated with growing trade.
[SPEAKER_05]: But what we also see, especially in African countries and low-income economies, that the fraction of trade that is in commodities is very, very high.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you can see that there on the left-hand side at the bottom, maybe a little bit small.
[SPEAKER_05]: The share of all commodities in very low-income economies that is pure commodities, not processed in any way, is very, very high, far over 80%.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that's a big challenge.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can we go to the next slide?
[SPEAKER_05]: So this is the share of African trade, global economy.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we know that the African economy has grown much faster over the last few decades than most other parts of the world.
[SPEAKER_05]: But the trade share is actually low.
[SPEAKER_05]: And in some sense, it has declined over time.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's mainly because of rising trade elsewhere.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it's lingering at around 2-ish, 3%.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think it's really important to keep in mind how far there is to go.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go to the next slide.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to skip that.
[SPEAKER_05]: The next slide.
[SPEAKER_05]: in the interest of time.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just to wrap up, there's risks to the global economy in particular, but also Africa.
[SPEAKER_05]: And one is growing geopolitical competition.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can see that there on the top left.
[SPEAKER_05]: We have a rise in AI, and it's not clear how that will impact African economies.
[SPEAKER_05]: We have climate change, and we have also increased uncertainty.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is the very last point I want to make.
[SPEAKER_05]: In most of the conversations we've had today, we talk about countries, and that's all good and well, but I think we need to drill down much more into details and actual problems that businesses face, and that's the very last slide I have.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I don't want to stop, I promise.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which is really, as an example of something that was very prominent last year in particular,
[SPEAKER_05]: the increase in tariffs that we've seen.
[SPEAKER_05]: In particular, this case is from the US, but there are other examples you could list, and how it's really confusing that increase in instability and also increase uncertainty about policy making.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's a huge problem.
[SPEAKER_05]: So this is just from newspapers.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tariffs means an economic growth for US firms.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is for importing firms in the US, but also confusion in paperwork.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we'll go to the next slide.
[SPEAKER_05]: It is, here's the Fed, U.S. Central Bank, saying the economy is slowing as companies can't figure out the rules of this tariff game, and this is for U.S. firms, and a lot of these firms are quite large and very sophisticated, and even those firms found it difficult.
[SPEAKER_05]: It goes on like this.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to stop here.
[SPEAKER_05]: But digging down into the detail of individual firms at the granular level, I think it's going to be increasingly important.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you very much for these highlights in the presentation.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'd like for us to
[SPEAKER_04]: pool that, all of that information into an FCBO Africa partnership on trade and investment, what would you propose, where do you see opportunity in that partnership?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would see a lot of opportunity in that partnership, especially at the level of expertise and technical cooperation.
[SPEAKER_05]: thinking much more about data and evidence in particular, and what we think is really important is impact and evaluation.
[SPEAKER_05]: So there's a lot of money that we spend, which is an extra job, because we don't mind a lot about organizations, and to get more rigorous with impact evaluation, I think, is an area where we can work together very, very well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, thank you very much to the panelists.
[SPEAKER_03]: Prof, do you want to say anything at this stage on the conversation we've had?
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think colleagues in the panel said it all.
[SPEAKER_05]: My colleague from South Africa, macroeconomic stability is like a foundation.
[SPEAKER_05]: It doesn't define the level of your goods, that you can be stable at the high level or stable at the low level, but you need that stability to be able to do the other reforms that will increase productivity.
[SPEAKER_05]: So for me, the continent should run while it can dance.
[SPEAKER_05]: We need to continue to double our GDP growth rate while we continue to invest on building that macroeconomic stability at all levels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because without it, we can't do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wonderful.
[SPEAKER_04]: Foundation Abroad issue.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm coming back to each of the panelists for one big action.
[SPEAKER_04]: One big action that's going to land trade, investment, and economic productivity in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: What would it be?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would say one big action is trying to look more at the data, and to really get a good understanding of how things are in the digital times and the digital markets.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll repeat that a little bit, that setting up a long-term goal, not just focusing on just short-term and long-term.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not surprising.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's saying that we come from a country that has that mindset.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Canadian politicians love silver bullets.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can tell you that there's none.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've been a public servant for over 25 years.
[SPEAKER_03]: So resist.
[SPEAKER_03]: Resist answering that question.
[SPEAKER_03]: And keep on thinking about all the marginal gains you can make.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because the big gains are very difficult.
[SPEAKER_03]: But if you keep moving forward with marginal gains, you get to the big gains.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thanks.
[SPEAKER_00]: So mine is not going to be something that they're really getting straight.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think financial development is particularly important.
[SPEAKER_00]: And financial development is about capital markets.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is about increasing households' use of financial products, credit extension, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_00]: What financial development also does is that the more people that participate in financial markets, the more exposure they have to the responses of financial markets to policy, to bad policy decisions.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see it in advanced economies.
[SPEAKER_00]: You also see it in South Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: the wrong minister of finance is appointed or somebody makes terrible announcements.
[SPEAKER_00]: Financial markets react.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if my pension portfolio decreases by 20% in response to some appointment, I'll be pretty upset.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so I think financial development mobilizes savings, increases the investment base, and it gives you this additional kind of dividend if you want to, which is strengthening institutions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would also say that generally Africa needs to leverage its own middle powers.
[SPEAKER_02]: So out of the seven economies, again, Africa needs to leverage its own middle powers.
[SPEAKER_02]: So out of seven systemically important emerging pivotal economies or middle powers of the south, two are Africa, Nigeria and South Africa.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can pursue a variety of strategies internally and externally.
[SPEAKER_02]: that deviate from traditional development models now.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can use sectoral diversification, they can pursue employment policies inside, and hedge for strategic partners externally.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they provide a lot of gravitas to regional integration, so that could be very viable, but also necessary.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so we've come to the end of this session, and we have such powerful insights that have
[SPEAKER_04]: helped us to answer this question, how do you harness the trade, investment, economic productivity nexus?
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to summarize what I picked up.
[SPEAKER_04]: The first thing is that to harness this nexus, we must think industry.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's where you started, I think.
[SPEAKER_04]: Industry is a big deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: And industry is not just the production itself, it's industry and infrastructure, industry and logistics, industry and
[SPEAKER_04]: that environment.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's the first thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: The second point is really around issues, governments, enabling environments, institutions.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of this has to work in an environment that almost is like a locomotive for that, brings the stability, the certainty.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that I would like to link to the point then around macroeconomic stability, that it is the foundational sort of anchor
[SPEAKER_04]: And what I understood then is that it's the confidence signal for the entire machine.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's the other point.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next point is that the African Continental Free Trade Area is an opportunity.
[SPEAKER_04]: An opportunity for effective partnership.
[SPEAKER_04]: An opportunity for joint ventures.
[SPEAKER_04]: That these joint ventures must be thought through with the long-term view in mind.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next piece is around data.
[SPEAKER_04]: Data is key.
[SPEAKER_04]: The final piece is around what I pick up as intra-African investment.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because our colleague from London talked about leveraging your powers within the continent, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: If our representative from Dengote was here, we would have seen the power of intra-African investment already.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I understand this idea of leverage, what you have by standing with the strong ones and using that as arteries to infuse intra-African investment.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we close off by saying there's no one single bullet, but there's certainly enough in what I've summarized to give us a sense that it is possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you very much.